i distinctively remember
one night where
my appearance was beginning to
drastically change and more and more
veins were starting to show up on the
right side of my face i like went into
my bathroom
got a towel wet it and just started
wiping my face because i was like this
can't be my life i can't like this can't
be my appearance this can't be
who i am now what i look like now
i'm nikki lilly and i was bullied
because of my face
my childhood was a super happy one but
when i was six years old i
started
having veins appearing on the right side
of my face and then that's when i was
diagnosed with an avm or arteriovenous
malformation
and you can get an avm anywhere in your
body um
they're quite common on limbs or in the
brain mine's on the right side of my
face and head and gums and behind my eye
anyone can have an ovm you're always
born with it but you could be 30 you
could be three you could be any age and
it can just start so that's what
happened with me up until the age of six
didn't know i had it didn't have any
symptoms looked like every other average
child average person and then at six
years old started getting symptoms of an
avm and that is when
my childhood changed and i went from
doing all of these activities and
spending time with friends going to
school five days a week to either being
at home or being in hospital
barely going to school barely
having any interaction with the outside
world and
i began to really hate myself i felt
like i
was just looking at my life
and was outside of myself and just
seeing it change and seeing everything
change around me it just made me feel
abnormal really i distinctively remember
one night where
my appearance was beginning to
drastically change and more and more
veins were starting to show up on the
right side of my face i like went into
my bathroom
got a towel wet it and just started
wiping my face because i was like this
can't be my life i can't like this can't
be my appearance this can't be
who i am now what i look like now
is there a single comment that sticks in
your mind from that time i was in a lift
with my mum and another um mom and her
child came in similar age to me and just
whispered loudly to their mom
mom she's so ugly and the mum being like
instead of telling the child that's not
okay um she just looks
special or she just looks unique or
something along those lines and using
that as a point to educate their child
saying it's okay darling we'll be out of
the lift soon
and that just made me feel
like another like that made me feel
like such an outsider and like
a monster and i remember this other
distinctive time where i came into
school one day and i had to work up a
lot of courage to come into school and i
saw my friends and i was so excited to
see them and one of my friends was just
talking to me and said you know nikki
like i don't even recognize you anymore
i was already my worst enemy i said all
the horrible things i could say to
myself internally
the last thing i needed was
to have people
on the outside
saying things that just made everything
i was going through harder for me i
could just see them staring at me and it
just made me not want to leave my house
my house just became my safe haven and
then how does your condition impact on
your
day-to-day life it affects my day-to-day
life one because there's currently no
cure um so i have like pain every day so
there's probably not a day that goes by
where i don't take painkillers through
operations and through having my
condition the nerve at the back of my
right eye has been damaged so
i am blind in that eye so i struggle
with seeing things properly so i don't
have i'm not able to see as much as
obviously the average person i can have
really really awful life-threatening
nosebleeds where i can lose a
horrendous like horror thing amount of
blood in such a small amount of time it
will also come like down the back of my
throat and out of my mouth that's where
i tend to lose most of my blood um and
also out of my tear duct so like i'll
literally be
crying blood so it's like literally like
a horror scene and sometimes you'll be
like to people oh yeah i have really bad
nice views and then they'll be like oh
yeah me too and i'm like i don't think
you do
i've had 95 operations i'd have them
every time that my bleed started getting
worse um to sort of keep things
temporarily at bay
so we're on the ward now this is the
ward that i'm going to be on after my
operation as well so post-op
anesthesiologist has just come and she
was so lovely she was so good wasn't she
mum yeah she was really good so they
have called me down to theater so mum is
quickly just tying the back of my
operating down um doctors would actually
cut my face and make a big incision and
try to remove some parts of my avm
rather than sort of blocking off parts
or trying to kill off parts with
medicine with operations like that you
have to make sure you don't get any
infections because they're literally
opening up your face and have to stitch
it back and
it's one where your appearance
massively changes it's it's very it
takes a big mental toll on you
i had an operation that didn't go very
well
and i ended up being quite severely
unwell and
ended up with some third degree burns
and because of
some treatment that i'd had which is
just a side effect of the one of the
medicines
a couple of years ago actually i started
having a really bad bleed and so was
taken
to the operating theatre and i woke up
eight days later um after being put into
a sleep induced coma for uh
eight days and was in intensive care and
then unfortunately this year my health
sort of gone back downhill and my
doctors are still sort of trying to find
a treatment for me i know that things
don't always go to plan when you have an
operation but it just felt very much
like every single odd was against me
and all i wanted was to be healthy so
then you started getting into like
vlogging hi youtube hi youtube hi
youtube how did that come about how did
that start
i'd always watched videos online because
that became my escapism you know from
the reality that was my life it was sort
of like youtube became my safe haven
and so i'd always film these videos on
our ipad um at home and one day i just
filmed a video rambling on about
something now recently i have been
hearing that loads of people have been
doing prom makeup looks from hairstyles
so i thought hey i can do a makeup look
i think it really helped in a way that i
never thought it would like me find
myself again
[Music]
it was like a project for myself and it
was a way for me to be the nicki that i
always was but i sort of felt like i
lost as after i got diagnosed and as my
appearance started changing started when
i was eight years old and
here i am really so yeah it's crazy i
never ever could have imagined it would
get here you're 17 now aren't you yeah
you've got 1.23 million subscribers on
youtube i love
that's a lot of people i never ever say
i'm proud of myself but like i am proud
of myself because
it really just was something that i
started doing because i had nothing else
i was left with nothing in my life and
so the fact that like the thing that i
just sort of started as a
spur-of-the-moment thing as a coping
mechanism for myself the fact that that
is the reason i'm like here today and
able to do what i do and able to sort of
like interact with other people connect
with other people similar to me you know
i've had parents coming up to me
um with their children saying that
they've been bullied a lot through the
years and really struggled with
accepting themselves and their
appearance because of that and my videos
have really helped them and that is
something where it's where little nikki
i know would be so proud of herself i've
got videos here that have 27 million
views yeah
that's a lot of people but it's like
obviously then you're going to get some
here too and some trolls how did that
have an impact on you
when i obviously there's a lot of
positivity online but when i did receive
the negative comments when i
especially turned my comments on i was
definitely nervous of what i was going
to receive and i did receive negative
comments like uh you're ugly why do you
look like that monster things like that
and it massively affected me it made me
question whether i wanted to
make videos it made me question
whether it was all worth it and it made
me sort of lose my love for it because i
would hone so much in on those negative
comments and then and this is a bit of a
strange question but like obviously the
comments will be on on this video if
there's if the people in there who would
say mean things to you
what would you want to say to them
now i would say
i forgive you um
i think that
as i've grown up i've realized that a
lot of people are going through their
own things and
you'll have bad days or go through
things where
they really affect us and affect our
mindsets and i think for a lot of haters
whether they want to admit it or not or
realise it
a lot of these comments that they say
come from a place of insecurity i see it
as
weakness and i see it as someone who's
clearly struggling in whatever form that
may be
clearly insecure
clearly
unhappy within themselves their own
lives
whatever it is and uses me as a
way to take out some of that insecurity
and unhappiness from obviously you got
to 1.2 million subscribers tonight and
from that you've got lots of
opportunities yeah
so you got a role as part of the bbc can
you tell me a little bit how that came
about and what it meant to you in about
2015 the bbc came to me and said that
they wanted to do a documentary about my
life as part of a series that they had
so i did that i did junior bake off at
the same time and won that from that i
ended up having my own series with them
spin-off show called nikki lily meets
and we did 40 episodes of that three
series where i was able to meet so many
amazing people public figures um
politicians singers so many different
people that i've always looked up to and
could have never imagined meeting i
interviewed theresa may when she was
prime minister um
in her office that was insane i made her
a quiche um i interviewed jeremy oliver
who i'm actually really good friends
with now nicole scherzinger really good
it doesn't get much better it doesn't
get any better than that and who else
jacqueline wilson loveliest person said
she wanted me to be her granddaughter um
who else have i done david williams
jeremy corbyn as well and he has like an
allotment so he brought along some jam
he made from his allotment and i made
some scones and we just sat on like
eight
like scones with his allotment jam and i
was like what is going on this feels
like a dream was and then i had like his
jam just sitting in my fridge and i was
showing everyone like this is jeremy
corbyn's jam
and yeah it was a crazy experience but
yeah i'm very very grateful for all of
it and have so many fun stories to tell
about the whole time that i did the
series is who'd be the who'd be the
dream next he'll be the one you're the
dream you'd love to meet would love to
do more musicians i'm a massive fan of
billy eilish so maybe one day well billy
is if you're watching oh god benny if
you're watching please i mean do you
know what my most viewed video is
actually a cover that i did of her song
[Music]
and she liked it on instagram so i guess
i don't know if she remembers who i am
but
really
please
so you've got a career in media what
kind of things did that came from that i
won um an emmy i was also nominated for
a bafta for
um my documentary about my life and then
i won another bafta called the special
award bafta which is recognition for not
like one show it's not one you win they
have to like assign it to you for
recognition over everything you've done
that a lot of people get at the end of
the chris i received pre-degenerate
award i won the japan prize award i won
pride britain awards and i've got a gold
blue peter badge if you want to count
that too it's been insane i mean it's
it's just been such a blur and when you
think about all those awards and you
think back to you age seven
staring in that mirror and wiping your
face
it's incredible to feel how far you've
come when i think back to
my little self
looking in the mirror just wishing that
my life wasn't mine and wasn't real
it is so insane to see how i've come
this far
it doesn't feel real and i wish that i
could just sit my little seven-year-old
self in front of like a tv screen to
look over like what my life would become
and i'm so glad that i had such an
amazing support network around me to
help me keep going and keep fighting
because when you're you have a chronic
illness
it's debilitating it's never ending it
never stops there's no break there's no
nothing and
among all the amazing things i've done
it's been insanely difficult to keep
going insanely difficult and i've been
through some really really low low
moments in my life it just reaffirms
that
i am strong and i think for anyone you
can do whatever you put your mind to
don't let where you come from what you
look like your circumstances anything
get in the way of you achieving your
dreams i think
yeah i just wish i could tell myself
that like you have no idea what you'll
be able to do and the power that you
hold as anyone does
at the time that i won i was loving my
mum and two bedroom council flat and i
was working at the scottish council for
volunteer organizations i was on like
eight pounds an hour but at that time
like that was a really good wage i was
17 so i already thought i was like
balling a bit so
it was a sunday afternoon